many of these tragic stories start with
domestic violence well homicides in
Metro's jurisdiction are actually down
this year experts say domestic violence
calls and incidents like this are up
this is Nevada ranks 18th in the nation
for women murdered by Men new at 11
Sasha Loftus joining us tonight with
step survivors and their families can
take to find safety Brian Advocates I
spoke with tonight say in most violent
or deadly situations like this abuse
escalates over time but they say
survivors and those who love them can
take action before the worst happens
you'll say wow if I would have stayed
that could have been me that Sandy
Vieira recalls the trauma she's faced in
her past relationships her stocking was
a huge thing or just that intimidation
she since started over and says it was
anything but easy we start to find
justifications for those actions and
then all of a sudden it's bigger things
now she's one of many who advocates for
those in domestic violence situations
and calls a recent string of murder
suicide cases here concerning
six people have died in three separate
situations just this week safeness CEO
Liz ortenberger says she's seen a 20
spike in domestic violence calls these
past few years and a lot of that's
related to the stress of covid now we're
going to add a layer of economic stress
to that while it's important for someone
struggling to ask for help she
encourages family and friends to also
speak up if something doesn't seem right
by having these courageous conversations
you are potentially stopping police
intervention so those experiencing abuse
can begin the difficult but important
process it's not easy I'll say that it's
never easy to find safety and peace find
resources find help even if it's
anonymous
safe Nest works with both survivors and
abusers and provides 24-hour help and
counseling if you need help you can call
or text their crisis hotline at
702-646-4981 we also have that on our
website 8newsnow.com